hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play elemental now
this is going to be a very different
playthroughs I have done in the past so
what I want you to do is sit back and
relax put on some headphones and crank
up the volume because this game I feel
like it deserves to be played with a
little bit of respect because if you
know me you know that I love indie games
and I love the indie game community
because I love what it represents to the
gaming community as a whole and
occasionally you'll get a game like this
that kind of goes beyond just the
gameplay of it and really represents
something more but I've been rambling a
bit too much I'm gonna show you guys
what it is as I'm playing it now I had a
chance to play this before but I'm not
gonna do a full playthrough of it don't
walk behind me I may not lead don't walk
in front of me I may not follow just
walk beside me and be my friend Albert
Camus now like I said I've played this
game before but I'm not gonna do a full
playthrough I just kind of want to give
you guys an idea of what it is all about
and give an opportunity to do a more
relaxed and a better commentary let's
play than I've done in the past because
I feel very strongly about these indie
games I need to find the other elements
but then again I've been rambling about
that for a while so this game you play
as one of four elements right now in the
beginning and you need to find the other
elements to combine them and use their
unique traits in order to be able to
travel through the world that you're in
and reach your end goal so for now you
are just an air bubble
and with that air bubble you can float
in air and you can try to bump up a
little bit as you try to move through
the world and water does not pop you but
if you touch the edges it definitely
will and like that like that right there
as you can see it may be a little
difficult for me to try to talk
seriously and think about what I'm
saying and play at the same time so I
apologize in advance if I die but one
thing about this game and the game
mechanics are very solid in the game I
want you guys to understand that it's
very very well done and very it's very
fun to play but more than that to this
game for me at least is the fact that
the atmosphere of the game is so
pervasive and enrapturing it is very
very easy to get wrapped up in what the
game is and I think a lot of that has to
do with the music of the game and if you
can tell already the music is pretty
amazing like I don't know what type
everyone has their own type of music
style that they like but for me
I don't listen to a lot of music I
listen to classical music or than
anything and I'm not saying this is
classical but it's definitely an
interesting music style but each level
has its own style that is really really
thoroughly enjoyable it makes the whole
experience something bigger than itself
because if you look at the art style of
the game it's very simple I'm not saying
it's bad it's simple there's a
difference between being simple and bad
but the art style of this game
it's just so happy and like you you feel
like you're exploring this entirely new
world and you're just this happy little
creature and the music can represent
that music is such a strong thing in
games that it's it's not always
exploited and I feel bad about some
games because some games have awesome
gameplay and yet they have really dull
music and some games have awesome music
and dull gameplay it can go both ways
but this game in particular combines
both in a really really interesting and
atmospheric way and that's why I highly
recommend that you guys play this for
yourself because this game is not short
by any means I think it's at least quite
a few hours worth of gameplay but it's
just this experience it kind of wraps
all together and creates something new
and bigger and for the $10 that I paid
for this game I would pay $10 easily
just to get a CD of the music in this
world and that's important to me but
then again I keep rambling about of the
same thing but you guys know me I can
ramble on and on about something forever
and get totally distracted from what I'm
doing which is probably means that I'm
going to play very poorly okay now let
me get back to the actual gameplay
commentary now I've got three different
elements with me right now and these
three elements are going to help me
traverse the world around me the stone I
can use in order to drop down and drop
down faster so that I can build up some
momentum as I'm traveling through the
world and I just momentum myself right
into that wall and really you're gonna
put me all the way back there how dare
you sir but now that I've got three and
there's only one left that I need to get
which you may deduce that it's fire that
I'm going to
and I don't think I got too little
momentum now but once I get fire
they'll be bound to all the arrow keys
and will help you travel through the
world and I would compare this game a
lot of it to a game that I actually
haven't had a chance to play and it may
seem like pretentious comparing it to a
game that I haven't played but um if you
guys have played the game journey on the
PlayStation 3 I think I would compare to
that and I'm gonna have to play that
very soon because I really love this
nondescript style of the game there
isn't really a solid objective to this
and I just got the fire element right
now which is the last element is going
to help me traverse even more stuff now
but uh in journey oh sorry a pair out of
thousands a connection that yields time
a deeper look into those colorful eyes
what happens when love collides
you
part-1 heart now like I said before I'm
not going to play through this whole
game the best and most beautiful things
in the world cannot be seen or even
touched they must be felt with the heart
Helen Keller who if you don't know was
blind and deaf okay so now that I've got
all of the characteristics I've got fire
ice and stone and air and I'm gonna use
these to go through but anyway what I
was saying before I'm trying not to
I often when I'm playing these games I
get distracted very easily and that's
not gonna be good I get distracted
easily I start saying something and
oftentimes I'll forget what I was saying
but I want this time um with journey
there's sort of this feeling of wonder
as you go through a world that you don't
know and you're just kind of flying
through the world and just going about
your business as the world wraps around
you and if I need to play journey very
soon because I've heard that it's an
incredible incredible well journey as
you try to just experience the game for
what it is and that's something that I
can truly appreciate in any game let
alone just an amazing amazing game like
journeyer from what I've heard again
I've only heard that it's good now I
have exploded apparently fire can't
touch fire so what am I supposed to do
there anyway I'm kidding I keep getting
sidetracked in a million ways I
apologize it's not very good so what am
i doing
hello okay I think when I was fire I
bounced off of that so let me try this
now coin yep there we go okay that's
what I thought nice thank you little
buddy you are smart enough to figure
this one out
am I
Rock to break through there we go tada
soul part found elements lost three well
that's not good lost sparks recovered
nerve two flagged time one oh three oh
four four alright so that is pretty much
as far as I'm going to get in this game
and you may be going No please play more
but I am really very serious when I say
you need to play this game for yourself
if you really enjoyed my playthrough of
this you are going to enjoy the game
even more like astronomically more sorry
I just hit my microphone there but
seriously not many games like this come
out often and not many games that
actually kind of touch you in a way that
you experience the game for what it is
so I would HIGHLY highly recommend going
out and buying this game it's only ten
dollars on Steam I'm not being paid at
all the promoted I'm just really adamant
about indie games that push the
boundaries of what the game designer
feels like his emotion and his desires
it is one go into creating what the game
is and it's sad to see that in a lot of
these triple-a title games big studio
games it loses a lot of the heart and
soul of what gaming is all about because
I mean it's not a bad thing that you
make these big games and a lot of great
games have been made and I applaud the
big studios that come out with these
really unique adventures and experiences
but I've yet to see something that
really connects as well as in the indie
game community I mean there's a few
games out there in the big title games
that have done but not as often or as
hard-hitting as some of these smaller
games like stylistically this game is
similar to limbo
you know in some of the blacks dating in
some of the world like that but limbo is
more atmospheric and dark and gritty and
just this really really gnarly
experience not gnarly isn't gnarly but
like gnarly experience and it's
something that can combine into
something with really simplistic
elements really simplistic gameplay that
can create something bigger and better
than the sum of its parts so honestly
give indie games a try if I had to get
any message out from this playthrough
give indie games a try
they might surprise you and they might
show you a new world that you could have
never imagined on your own so anyway I'm
gonna leave it at that
I hope you enjoyed this playthrough and
I hope you enjoy the game so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos and I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video